press space to honk honk honk honk honk
oh yes I really love this game double
click to run
let's go gamer stolen dark simulator if
he doesn't play this game I don't know
what I won't get everything Hong Kong
Hong Kong to use my beak I can do stuff
bling bling bling bling bling bend down
to pick things up of the ground press
ctrl - yes oh I have little can honk
honk i can't honk with the cannon mouth
sad and then let it go let it go honker
let it go let's grab this so cute he's
so adorable
it's a fakie simulator why am I doing
this I don't know oh I got it don't get
it
maybe that will change hey I did it I
must be some sort of duck genius am i a
duck ah what's the difference between a
goose and the geese that's right
controls are a little strange I'm not
gonna lie what oh here it comes oh boy I
didn't do it
but whatever I thought I was gonna fly
sandwich mine now
honk-honk sandwich belong in water dip
it now it tastes better now we give it
back whoever finds it will be happy what
is this give me this
Hong Kong let's hide it in the water
let's give what give it a little bath
there you go
honk honk you're a live track like this
if you're a goose that's just life
everyone knows same hey can we
oh I don't want to play the radio to
zoom in zoom out okay all right I keep
wanting to move with wasd yeah
yes listen up soldiers it's a new regime
happening are there no people in this
game honking there's nothing shut follow
me follow me dum-dum this way this way
here it is you want this no no no no get
it back oh now I'm pissed you suck
peepee oh okay okay fine well sneak well
sneak in sneak after him mine I hate you
I'm friendly
I swear I'm so friendly now I miss
give it give it to me give it to this
like Dark Souls fine I'm in the guard
you'll regret this why am I not grabbing
it oh it's right click I keep forgetting
hello you want gift very well
[Music]
mine bye bye
I never burst I never take it again bye
bye bye bye so fast you can never catch
it's really hard to run with it stop
you're not my real father
can activate the hose hose man
hose man ha ha god you're stinky stinky
dinky smell like pee pee dummy dumb dumb
you should steal his boots my boot let's
hide it underneath share yes
where am I supposed to go you'll never
get me alive
haha yeah what are you gonna do
Oh God he follows me know whatever
yes I locked them out haha and now for
the best bait my garden my garland BB
bubble you want these you'd cease what
you want you cannot that stupid stinky
[Music]
my garden my rules
say you're sorry then that will forgive
oh yeah my garden rules
heck yeah this card is awesome
oh I like my baby that my goblin Deborah
day fine
actually I don't know how to open for
you okay so apparently there's a to-do
list make grande keeper where his Sun
Hat raking the lake have a picnic raking
the lake shouldn't be too hard
come here rake rake to the lake here we
go
oh god we're in a stealth mission we got
to be careful yes the radio serves as
excellent decoy rake in the lake
raking the lake gamers we did it
next up we I gotta have a picnic okay
mmm
moist sandwich my favorite my favorite
flavor moist tastes so good
is this all I have today just grab them
from there is that nice I'm having a
picnic guys what else do you use a
picnic for boot
maybe the picnic basket yeah that would
make sense
yeah this has to be it
what oh I need a blanket pumpkin carrot
Jam and sir oh wow I need a lot of
things I didn't see there
sorry if I'm illiterate I'm an actual
duck wow I have to steal so many things
good thing I'm an excellent thief Jam
thermos pumpkin and bullying hey hey not
doing anything hey hey I'm not
suspicious at all mmm delicious Jam
follow me Jam you're my new best friend
Jam was like a father to me
what will I even do with this Jam I
can't even open it doesn't matter the
picnic needs to happen
such a cute game I brought their music
that's a bonus alright so thermos and I
think pumpkin and blanket hey hey not
doing anything bad Thermage yo Inc he's
so dumb dumb dumb dumb
okay now just a pumpkin I don't know who
the heck has a pumpkin picnic but you
know I'm not judging your pumpkins stop
fighting my god you're so heavy what
would I find a blanket I don't know if
I've seen a blanket do they mean the
actual blanket because I am sitting on a
blanket okay that was a yes if I keep my
mouse here it looks like I had swallowed
a stone or something okay
make grunt keeper hammer his thumb what
that's the mean I love it honk-honk
honk-honk
Chang Qing yang yang Yang Chang Qing is
our national anthem in Sweden actually
yang yang Yang what that is bigoted
racist and not epically stop it stop
that sign mine abuse abuse at the oh Sh
animal abuse this is rat oh my god how
do I make him hammer his thumb oh I by
turning down the sign you like this
this is what I think of your sign huh I
don't make him hammer his sign his thumb
Walli hammers me scare him or something
[Music]
I'm sorry am i disturbing you
he's gonna do it oh my god I'd I kill
them dum dum dum dum don't like you
anyway alright we progressed awesome
hello just secured moving downtown
trying to make it in this world where
should he go Oh nerd nerd make you play
for tonight bet you played uh me fourth
night go cry to your mama go cry my mama
my mama cry cry cry cry cry dum-dum
you sewed all my ugly or what you have
stupid stinky nose stinking those stinky
nose think zing zing zing zing zing zing
zing zing oh I want your sneeze
give me your knees yes mine hi your
shoelace is untied
ha ha ha ha dum dum oh my god yes oh you
can't see big mommy mommy mommy mom
sophisticated good librarian goose don't
touch me don't touch me
why am I so mean I'm an actual bully oh
this is his toy dump toy bet he doesn't
even know how to fly it
okay break broom Wow trap the boy in the
phone booth make the boy wear the wrong
glasses okay that's cool let's do that
since we're already kind of on to that
always put this down the sewer
there we are no illegal illegal illegal
hey hey up on them take him
aah oh my god he's a zombie
[Music]
take here you go child you're welcome
that will be 50 bucks dumb child okay
what else can we do to the boy cuz he's
more fun trap the boy in the phone booth
okay not the music
ah where's the phone booth oh so we're
in England where's the phone boy phone
then wha dokoni it should be pretty
distinct cuz the hell of this here it is
when you K now how would I trap him play
play with me play play play play or you
can play football
hello child hey hey
that's a nice little toy you have there
would be a shame if anything happened
[Music]
how would I possibly do that
Oh get on TV what go shopping pudding
basket toothbrush and lube paper I'm
going shopping
[Music]
oh we have to steal her stinky broom how
do I break the broom then it's like an
actual puzzle game can I not Oh God
go go go go go yes now we need to break
it
dumb kid runaway child zips up sticks up
tips up sticks up sticks epic I know I'm
not very good at this game by the way
but it's fun anyway how do I get on TV
tinned food fruit and vegetable with a
carrot count this fruit
I mean vegetable come on I'm just
shopping no will she take it out oh you
stink you're a sneaky person let him man
I mean goose shop around alright I'll
have to put it further away
[Music]
one day in society gooses can shop all
they want shop shop dumb child she took
everything from me you took everything
from me I don't even know who you are
chop chop
[Music]
yeah what are you gonna do use your
broom stink but that it that they let it
aaaa
how do you break the broom let's check
out over here maybe I can open the
garage nope
I can use the I use this a shield
[Music]
listen up ghost's people George people
will rise what are you gonna do I have a
shield no fine I'll steal potatoes now
stop okay here's the broom what about
these Gameboy stuff
I just walkie-talkies oh I get it I can
throw her off by making goose noises
there oh I can kill the electricity the
one why would I do that
[Music]
yeah where's your broom b-word and now I
yell in walkie-talkie
this is goose over haha scared her
[Music]
okay so that confuses the child
he wants his football but how do I get
him inside there I have to break the
glass or something oh maybe I can trick
them with a walkie-talkie
let's try that I need my walkie-talkie
bang will that make them come out it's
working it's working it's working
yes you fell for the old trick no I was
so close oh now he's locked in stop
looking at me child damn let me sign III
said there's a button here isn't it oh
[Music]
I'm on TV
I'm on TV I'm on TV I'm on TV I'm famous
famous YouTube subscribe it I mean don't
do it I mean do it yeah whatever yeah
yes right subscribe check out my youtube
channel check out YouTube channel that
got Bo Dollis why is being the worst
person the greatest thing ever the
developers of this game truly understood
all right let's do the shopping thing
really quick
that's kind of boring actually the fun
stuff make someone buy back their own
stuff also if I steal his toy plane will
he have to buy it back
Oh virgin virgin but you don't know how
to dribble bet you don't know to dribble
virgin bet you don't let her dribble
what she's moves run out though
slot done oh yeah oh yes and always your
plane oh hey
your plane is over here you're stinky
plane is over here oh there's your plane
wow he just took it that's illegal
oh he's flying it he's buying it back
dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb no no no no no
no he's lying that's right buy it back
by it yeah bargain bargain smells are
stinky stinky stinky all right well
they're preoccupied I should probably
take some canned foods delicious
nutritious nothing more nutritious yes
I'm a responsible duck what can I say
now she's now you're free alright
whatever
let's grab the haberdashery there we go
very nice how would I break that how
would I break the broom
[Music]
and how do I get him in the phone booth
I know I open the phone can I pull the
car now mine
stink stinky stinky Oh where'd he go the
bushes speaking to you
impossible how could you find me
impossible where's the stinky boy hey
you are stinky stinky stinky pinky pinky
yeah yeah yeah go in there go in their
stink stink stink
you smell like potatoes you're locked in
aren't you ha ha ha
is that his parents trap the shopkeeper
in the garage how
what how do I even open the garage no
she put up a sign it's so good
oh here's the garage oh I just have to
trap her in okay hey stinky stinky
follow me stinky that's right that's why
polos think you think you think you
thinking now got him trapped I need to
yeah come on haha
thanks thanks eh hold him to go shopping
what you like it oh this one looks good
yes yes go play somewhere else virgin
I love letters let us so good it is not
letters what oh I need it I definitely
need a hairbrush I've been looking for a
perfect everything is free that's such a
great price amazing
okay hairbrush yes look what else do we
have
toothbrush I'm pretty sure that's at
night that's definitely in no it isn't
there we go
tinned food and cleaner that should be
easy
all the cleaning spray alright I know
where that is you better not mess this
up for me boy
better not call your mom on me again
stinky boy oh she has two cleaner dammit
sorry I wasn't meaning to say that out
loud
you better not you better not she better
not she's looking for it I'm not taking
any chances
I'm not the strongest geese in the Wild
West but I am the most persistent one
okay this is gonna take forever
I need that spray maybe I need to use
the walkie-talkies she holding it no
she's not don't mind me keep doing your
job yes that was the garage many spiders
well she better not
oh come on come on I'm just a duck in a
lonely world joint
mother-fricker yes blocks the loo paper
fell out I need a lot of paper yes
go away child go away hey joy
Thank You blinky alright what's next
make it dinner all great I locked myself
in the garage all the gate is open now
no not like this I'm sorry I don't have
thumbs
hello oh please some of the gate is same
yeah it's all same later fatty tuna
I love fatty tuna never mind here we go
bleep blop blip blop blip blop blip blop
blip blop honk honk big flop flip flop
flip flop flip flop flip flop Hong Kong
flip flop flip what there's nowhere to
go here oh never mind
yes yes hello everyone what's happening
oh they're playing cricket can i play
crap yes of course here we go I just
want to play cricket leave me alone
leave me alone just want to play cricket
this is racist or what this neighs Oh
oopsie
this looks valuable I'm gonna take it
yeah I'm in your garden oh my god what
is this this is the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen in my life I want it for
me Oh Mykel buddy
she has an odd tasting statues I'll I'll
say that
hahaha young iOS my to-do list
make someone break the fancy base help
woman dress up the bust make the man
spit out his tea get dressed up with a
ribbon let's get this out of the way now
it's stuck dang it
I'll have to steal some bring up can we
draw can we draw painting
[Music]
I need to distract her to go far away I
said a bong yes I need to be quicker now
let's place let's place that there this
place at ourselves here yes yes do it
know what they did nothing
what oh yes grab it please please do it
come on
just a normal little duck with this
little tiny plug you sit down use a
stinky flip-flop Piplup Piplup LUP
Piplup LUP LUP LUP LUP LUP LUP LUP ah
stink wow that's the most basic fan art
I've ever seen in my life
all right let's wait for him to take a
slurp of his tea and then we're gonna
slam the Frick out of him look at him
he's so ready
yes tickler
drink drink drink yes drink yes drink
drink drink
hahahaha xxx think think think think
think think think think think think
think think think think I want to go
back I can't go back how do I go back in
Oh
oh wow okay so that's how you doing man
I'm starting to feel bad I'm so mean
okay we're back in gamers I have I look
cuter than ever you like this no you
cannot take away my bow that's my most
precious item in the whole world know
what stink you suck
you'll pay for this you'll pay dearly
for this I'm gonna you'll pay for the ah
there it is there it is
[Music]
damnit I have to sneak them off I
understand I'm not doing anything not
doing anything okay maybe I need to
sneak better yes how he's good he's good
I'll give it to him out he's good
yes yes no he saw me oh he doesn't know
where he went
stinky stinky oh oh I see oh I see yeah
what
that's so cute Sherlock Holmes ah come
on
I didn't hey hey sorry continue enjoy
your afternoon sir my apologies how's
your tea
bing-bong bing-bong barefoot he's
barefoot yeah Big Mike mmmm I don't care
you can have it I get threw it away so
he can't oh there it is never mind I was
next
help woman dress the bust very well
sometimes you gotta help gamers
[Music]
hurry run duck run no it's trapped I'm
trapped
dang it I'll get you one day that must
be it right
he knows I'm about to do something
[Music]
Scott better bury me whatever David
everything ding ding ah sad Sherlock
Holmes coming through
no again are you I so close yes yes
where did it go ha ha
right on wrong side okay we gotta hurry
up before she closes stupid dingdong
your dingdong lady all right where's the
bust there you go
you're welcome oh she's doing something
grab it honk honk honk yes yes my child
yes yes yes
ok we I guess we need more items you did
something right for once
all right here we go
hey hey hey Sherlock Holmes coming
through
[Music]
don't look at me dammit don't got him
hey hey oops
that's the fancy vase of course I
thought I was a bone all right drop it
doom Rambam up up up up up up
how do I break the fancy base and then I
suppose we need the glasses as well yunk
wrong side of the hood mother-fricker
it's better not all my every time how
nifty is she give it give it back
sophisticated duck haha giving up Dom
making my way downtown walking how did
she get that in his mouth in legal so
the vase how did we break the vase I
gotta escape with the vase you can't
follow doc up here
[Music]
my oh he's gonna try and take it dang it
don't do it
oh my gum dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb
dumb dumb through the washing with a bra
pair of socks Slifer at a bar of soap
okay um he broke your vase it wasn't me
I swore I swore okay I see a bar of soap
here and how do I wash me excuse me I'm
trying to do dishes over here fine you
can have it you can have it legit you
can you're looking for your vase dum-dum
you have a toilet in your backyard by
the way get up walk over here maybe
later
all right so it's our water anywhere ah
yes here's the bra
[Music]
hey yes I got it
no why would you steal it
where's some water help woman dress up
the bus okay finally in it nice
that gives us a new make someone room
the price rose oh she's gonna do this
revenge that's hilarious
[Music]
yes follow me Chad oh here's the water
okay excellent sock sock on these socks
blip blop blip blop blip blop blip blop
blip blip you'll never catch me a live
woman you never catch me alive yes
that's how it's done watch time hello
watch time he better not there it is
watch time
so cute all right we got are you
enjoying this I'm having fun at least
yeah let's do the shortcut this summer
and have time to walk around every time
not bad not bad at all actually man I
need both the socks okay
[Music]
was something I could do a pro-gamer
move hopefully she follows me here
instead
yes follow me child hey hey I didn't do
anything
I'm innocence no don't worry about don't
worry about that right now
luckily she's slow as a blob blob that's
a word yes um oh no don't don't
tattletale
I'll take your stuff then I'll take your
stuff ah come on
I just need slipper and a pro soap right
I put the borrow slip again there it is
do I need to hide them from him maybe
that makes it a lot harder you see like
clearing it out how we could do it I
might as well go for it because if I
drag this oh oh I see I thought she was
gonna deliberately do it there's
something in the bushes I don't push me
out whoa that's a pro-gamer move oh my
god there's something in the bush you
better cut it better cut it done yes do
it do it yes don't deny she did it
where's your titties I mean bra voice or
bra I seriously need it where is it
[Music]
see that pervert take her bra where is
it where's her bra
ah yes it worked yes now we just need
his slipper excellent okay we've done
this before
hello hey hey I'm just looking over here
going no no no no no no no and it's we
did it oh he's rose Oh for me Senor oh
come on it was a joke it was a joke
get over yourself it was a joke did we
do it all I think so
oh he's pissed
yes
yes keep fighting yes yes what are you
gonna do with that pervert pervert
bling blong Bing bong Bing bong bong
bling blong bling blong oh nice catch
buddy what's wrong with you so we did
everything does not unlock a new area I
think it does automatically so maybe I
should just leave alright it's been real
gamers be pop pop pop I love this game
so fun we pop it but it's out for the
switches well I think Marcy would like
it we're gonna be flying soon so ah she
fixed surveys that's cute I might get it
for her oh oh strut strut strut are you
talking to huh oh wow that is an bad
sign
oh so now I can go through here that was
what the sign was hahaha that's
hilarious
I don't know if you guys saw that that's
funny I have no one to play with
this is so sad I had one of those goals
oh my god sorry gives me a PR made it
did anyone make delivery yes
this way
make delivery can you go Medicare or
solid on this one can i yes you can yes
it's a box grab the box yes
dumb you're dumb we got into the pop
gamers what's up no no no no I'm just a
duck I'm just a doctor sheesh bling
blong bling blang blang all right we're
in the pub oh yes do you want to play
this guy doesn't want to play with the
dang this guy's a very slow all right
you can have it back I don't care
well can we play darts please all right
so what are our new missions break the
dartboard get the toy boat make the old
man full dollars bump be awarded a
flower look still the pint glass drop it
in the canal set the table okay this can
all be done ooh this is a grill can we
grill some duck
[Music]
food please hungry hello Hungary Hungary
please food hey hey Oh it's sneaky time
yes why am I doing this for all the boat
the boat will escape the boat will rise
[Music]
you're free my boat
now
[Music]
I can add under the tables you'll never
catch me old lady can I unscrew the cork
come on gotta pull it there it is beer
is free everyone you're welcome
I love these sort of open world type of
puzzle games we mix exploration and it
reminds them b-movie @d s actually do it
Punk ah
do it do it do it do it
Oh lame get the toy boat I thought we
had a chance
well maybe now we do actually she better
not have turn off the tap why am i why
do I make it harder for my huh rice to
my glorious rice yes mine mine mine
lalala please please please
where did he go he cannot possibly be
found mine
oh come on Lady you stink
no that was my chance I ruined it yeah
yeah I get it now I got it nice nice you
are forever mine little but forever mine
I will play with you a little bit I will
play with you over here blip blop blip
blop blip blop blip blop but you can't
even hit a bling blang one two three
sorry at it did I say something today
something bad honk honk ah ha ha why you
want to fight come at me bro come at me
bro oh you want something you want
something what is this what are you
thinking we're gonna pull out a knife on
me make the old man fall on his bum be
awarded a flower still a pint and drop
it in the canal that should be easy
No she is on there on the job sorry
listen look like oh is this the canal no
this is not the canal this is just say
I'm a ding-dong now I really done it no
I want that pint
I'm drowning the pint glass she's
thinking where to go
sorry it was me I'll take the full blame
what are you gonna do put me in goose
jail there's no such thing
guru seems like the kind of animals that
you think would be fun to have as a pet
but in reality not epic you know I'm
saying can I be awarded for setting the
table perhaps I might have to reset
because I think I need that pint glass
[Music]
there it is there it is
yes yes that was so hard I struggled so
bad I'm sorry
actually I'm not on my couch don't care
honk-honk alright can i impress you
ladies can I do something for you hello
hey hey oh you like it hey Hong flex
winks yeah lay like this what does he
like thanks ladies
wink wink still a pint glass and drop it
in the canal looking for your chair old
man dog yeah I'm gonna have to resit
this one just to get the pint glass back
no I dropped the pop glass oh come on
dude there must be more than one yes
there is okay thank God we must distract
him
dum-dum cheese for the drink my cheese
oh god he's after me
I know we're almost at the canal no you
suck so much peepee you have to be
kidding me
we were so close stink there better not
be just two pint glasses
what kind of published this where you
have two glasses maybe over here yes
there is a last one
[Music]
some of these are a lot harder than the
others
[Music]
where the guard go oh god he's there
sneaking duck noises we did it yes why
did I do this because I'm a mother bye
bye
yeah all right what do we have left set
a table okay
drop bucket on the burly man's head
what's a burly man the entrance guy
hey hey it's kind of hard to get into
the pub honestly yeah actually it's very
easy just untie your shoes ha ha ha dum
dum hope you break your stupid face oh
they're putting up signs now
discrimination alright we'll help them
make them feel better so we need to
pepper candle knife and fork all right
there's a knife did it how am I gonna
reach and what table am i setting
there's the pepper maybe the one in the
garden perhaps yeah there must be one in
the garden oh here it is of course it's
like lady in the isn't it could
that be it yeah it has to be it
all right so we have pepper I think I
saw a plate back here yes oh god do I
need a glass plate Kendall nice okay
thank God I'm out of those spices yeah
you're not gonna stop me don't even try
I'm a duck I get hungry as well ain't my
problem ain't my problem you're stinky
dinky all right let's get the pepper
[Music]
mission will be easy compared to the
glass in the frickin river one are in
the candle as well I don't know what the
candle Isis but it shouldn't be too hard
that lady better not mess up my game
like the Biergarten guy did I bet it
yeah where's your pepper dumb-dumb yeah
this is it oh yeah
pepper redux we do like our pepper not
candle no no no no no no no no no I mean
it's a
[Music]
oh I saw the candle who's the no duck
sign for for ducks
come on Lady this is the last piece just
let a duck enjoy his dinner without his
food just the table all alone there we
go I got to bend my neck for this one
and it's beautiful
no maybe not oh oh you better not mess
with this I I forgot the knife where
have I seen a knife and if a duck should
be running around with a knife that
sounds like a military death situation
ah there it is never seen you don't come
near me I will cut you don't come near
me don't come here okay okay Kay I'm
sorry sorry sorry sorry
ah come on give me mine don't care what
you say I will enjoy my dinner look how
beautiful I set this table guys thank
you
oh yeah drop a bucket on the burly man's
hand so I seen the bucket there it is we
just need to go on top here wait for the
burly man clearly this burger man has
very low regard
where I got to put them where do you go
oh there is oh okay that explains it
it's the burly man the guy on the front
oh oh no I made a mistake no not like
this
[Music]
follow me haha thank you
take a follow me is he giving up
you got bullies so hard he could oh he's
still tying his shoes
[Music]
gotta make him come through here yes Tom
Joe job oh what a mess it created Oh God
she's not gonna mess up my game I have
achieved epicness ha ha thanks exact
same thing ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ha ha ha ha yes even better than
expected maybe he goes and washes up now
is that what happens let me go crying to
his mama how do I get to the other area
I'm so confused
oh maybe now I can oh I see it
of course he opened the trash I'm
absolutely 9,000 IQ which makes me the
smartest goose alive
big brain I'll keep moving that by
accident sorry let's sound like this for
other fellow gooses in the future yes
blip blop blip blop blip blop blip blop
blip 'ln hello what is this tedious
tenant Engel Appy through the water are
we where are we
my flower I swim I flap my wings I'm in
the model marriage
I'm Gizella haha yeah feel my wrath oh
oh wow that's heavy I hate to stinky oh
this is a minimum this is how we walk
through the city oh yeah this is the
house who made this and why oh this is
matter oh wow hmm well of reckoning
this truly is Dark Souls take back back
back back back back back back back back
back back back back back back
drag that buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
yes yes it will be mine
yes yes it will be mine it will be mine
almost almost hours hours although my I
have achieved well still the bell of
golden excuse me
and take it all the way back home yes
yes oh can I run
oh it rings if I run okay this should be
interesting
I can't even find my way back home nice
I swear it's here
ding-ding-ding Thapa morning jack would
love this game there it is alright so
now we know the route at least since
instances okay alright
blip blop blip blop I assume as soon as
I run a ring someone's gonna mess with
me
hey lucky me I opened the gate for my
son okay
[Music]
just a goose coming through without it
shoes
oh they see the bell of reckoning they
want it but you cannot have a look it's
potato man I'm taking no chances
[Music]
mine mine it will never be yours where
am I
[Music]
where is this I've I've been here oh of
course
oh okay but where's the lady oh there
she is
don't touch me oh no she fixed her
stupid thing oh I hate you I hate you I
hate you I hate you you better give me
back that thing or else they would be
sued mine they're mine
understand I've to open the gate of
reckoning don't know I can't shoot let's
hide it there she will never know bail
of reckoning yes I hate you dummy
that's a bail
how you like that Apple bells bottom
jeans books with yes she better not be
fixing that shell thing hey know what
they did nothing mine give it back
[Music]
stole stole I made the stole so how do I
escape from the old man he had a hole in
his fence he fixed his fence oh god how
do I get out get out of my sight oh god
I can hold everything what'd I do
how do I get past it
[Music]
not looking not looking this is what you
do all day being a stinky peepee poo-poo
alright fine I'll grab your magazine
looks what's in the news you're a dummy
dumb yeah that's in the news if I read
about that dummy dumb looks what look
like it's taking the belt of Isengard
illegal illegal
mine by gamers see you never gamer
bye-bye you cannot stop me I am
invincible
okay now we watch normal flip flop flip
flop flip flop that shop lady better not
cost me any problems or if she oh we got
a locker in the garage don't we it's
gotta be done gamers I'm going for it
oh wow it's such good oh wait who are
you hello I take what I learn and I
apply to real life's baho
get the rekt noob
[Music]
stealth I am thus tell the boy better
not go near mix I'll keep freaking
choppers NECA into tiny love virgin
pieces are you snake how do we get past
him how about we just bark at him hey
get out of my sight
get out a nice a get out here shush go
me cry to your mama you stinky mama
you're a stinky stink stinking pool hold
on you're not virgin you're just
pathetic bling bling bling bling bling
bling
no you do not go near me I kill you Lily
Lily Lily Lily Lily Lily Lily Lily Lily
no one touches me Oh God oh we gotta
stop here gamers I don't like this guy
I like this guy one bit we're stealthy
oh he's waiting for us huh well I know
his weaknesses sis being a fool being a
damn for put you down
what does he hate the most water gross
oh I get it we got it we got to do this
this is the way the sacred Scrolls it
will be mine justice will be mine yes
sweet savory Bell no one can touch you I
love you so much you are my child you
are like father to me I love you
yes escape victory near Oh Oh everything
not as planned
we made it sweet and we are free at last
ding ding ding ding couple morning where
is our home remember it was across the
river down by the river
[Music]
give me crusted yes yes we're almost our
gamers very subtle here at their final
lap this is it
or was it here I don't remember exactly
where we started this is the greatest
backtracking mission of all no that's so
funny oh my god is great
honk-honk great game
oh so fun I love that that may be life
[Music]
I hope you guys had fun watching check
out the game yourself I highly recommend
it super fun to play and have a great
time I have a great life and goodbye
[Music]